Eddie, so good to talk to you.
And I ask everybody this thing.
How old were you and where were you that...
...music started, you know,...
...being a thing for you.
I think love of music.
Had a couple uncles,...
...I was the oldest of the kids but I got a couple uncles who,...
...you know, I'd steal their Beatles records.
I remember stealing Yellow Submarine,...
...Woodstock, had a lot of stuff...
...so that was, I was five or six.
So you started singing first?
Yeah, I picked up a guitar when I was about 12.
Kinda toughed it out for a bit and at one point,...
...I gave myself a certain amount of years...
...to do something as a musician...
...and played in bands here and there and got better at it.
And then ended up in Seattle.
How'd you go out to Seattle?
A good friend of mine got an offer to play drums in a band up there.
And then they said, "By the way do you know any singers?"
And he threw me a tape, recorded on a 4-track...
...that morning like three songs then sent 'em off and never thought anything about it and then...
...couple of weeks later they flew me up to Seattle and we started playing together.
You know, it's funny because we've been listening to that stuff recently...
...'cause we put out some of that early demo stuff and I hadn't heard it...
...since, what, 18 years ago or something.
And it was interesting to hear, almost terrifying because...
...I don't really remember spending more than three or four hours on these three songs.
But it was probably, in the end, you know, I look to where I have a family now,...
...I think it was like the best life I've ever lived.
That's history.